es momento de hablar de salud en directo
América y ya nos acompaña a más Romero
sala en el estudio buenos días Rosa mar
hablemos de un tema que ha centrado
nuestra atención y la de la mayoría de
medios de comunicación en las últimas
horas hablamos de la salud del Papa de
Roma hablamos de la salud del papá que
ve por suerte ha superado con éxito la
cirugía a la que estaba sometido y pues
sabemos que con estas personalidades y
especialmente cuando son tan mayores
todo puede convertirse en un problema
todo puede ser un susto en este caso la
operación se conoce como la parotomía
que es todo lo que abre digamos el
abdomen para poder examinar o tratar
cualquier dolencia que exista allí no es
una cirugía especialmente compleja pero
Digamos como eso no como requieran
anestesia general para personas mayores
todo puede complicarse por Suerte este
no ha sido el caso parece por ahora en
este caso la cirugía se debió a una
hernia que es cuando hay un órgano o un
tejido que sale de manera anormal
digamos por el tejido de la pared
abdominal y eso es muy doloroso en en el
caso la hernia recibía recibe el nombre
de la perocele que significa que se crea
digamos encima de una cirugía de una
cicatriz perdón de una cirugía previa y
lo que hicieron en el que consistió esta
intervención fue sacar la hernia y
sustituir además la parte del intestino
digamos que quedó dañada por una especie
de prótesis un tejido que pueda cumplir
con las mismas funciones para evitar
este dolor que estaba provocando el
bloqueo intestinal que puede estar
provocando no se cree por esto de esta
cicatriz que comentábamos que la cirugía
está relacionada con la que ya recibió
el papa en julio de 2021 se sometió una
operación de colon fue la primera vez
que ingresó que tuvo un ingreso
hospitalario en a su pontificado que
empezó en 2013 y en ese momento se
extrajeron ya 33 centímetros de colon
del intestino grueso por diverticulitis
que es cuando hay unas inflamaciones e
infecciones en el colon en el final del
intestino grueso también recordemos que
como decíamos no es el primer problema
de salud del papa y también hace poco en
este mismo mes de marzo ya tuvo que ser
ingresado también por una infección no
pulmonar en este caso el ingreso en el
que está ahora es el tercero por lo
tanto Bueno Este es el progreso del
estado de salud del Papa esperemos Por
supuesto que todo que todo vaya bien
pero sí sí sabemos que estamos en
momentos que requiere este monitoreo y
esta complicación No claro María es él
ha expresado en varias ocasiones su
voluntad un poco ya de dejar el cargo no
pero también hay incertidumbre en quien
lo podría reemplazar al frente de la
Iglesia Católica y es que tiene como
dices varios problemas de salud otro
añadido y son problemas de rodilla que
requieren una operación que parece que
él quiere evitar no porque pues parece
por lo que sabemos por los comunicados
que hay en el Vaticano que lo que quiere
evitar a toda Costa es una anestesia
general que en este caso de hecho no ha
podido esquivar han tenido que someterlo
a anestesia general sabemos que a raíz
de la operación de 2021 precisamente de
la que hablábamos quedó reticente a
estos efectos secundarios que pueden
tener una anestesia general
Especialmente cuando se hace de nuevo en
personas de edad avanzada no sabemos Eso
sí a Qué efectos secundarios se refiere
específicamente esto no lo han
comunicado Pero sabemos que a pesar de
que la anestesia general es muy segura
si puede dar algunos problemas si hay
condiciones médicas previas o si el
paciente como decíamos es un adulto
mayor hemos buscado especialmente Cuáles
son estos efectos secundarios en los más
preocupantes son los que existen a nivel
cognitivo y son los más prevalentes
especialmente como decíamos en personas
mayores hay una mayor prevalencia de lo
que se llama delirio postoperatorio que
es cuando hay la confusión la pérdida de
atención desorientación justo después de
la cirugía que suele pasarse rápido y
también hay una mayor prevalencia de lo
que se llama disfunción cognitiva
postoperatoria que es cuando estas
alteraciones persisten hasta tres meses
después de la operación Es verdad que la
prevalencia como hemos podido llegar a
hasta el 41% de este disfunción
cognitiva y pues entendemos en este caso
no que ser un Papa seguir trabajando
tener un cargo tan importante con estas
dolencias Pues debe ser complejo y debe
querer evitarlo a toda Costa es
comprensible en este caso no totalmente
mar y aunque no tengas un cargo así no
siempre entrar en quirófano pues asusta
un poco mar dejemos este tema de lado y
pasemos a otra cuestión vamos a uganda
porque la severas leyes homófobas
abiertamente homófobas que está
legislando el país tienen impacto sobre
la salud de la población no Así es rosa
Lamentablemente nos basamos en un
reportaje de la agencia reuters que
fueron a una clínica donde se
proporciona atención
cuidados y tratamientos sobre varias
enfermedades pero especialmente sobre el
VIH es una clínica que solía recibir 50
pacientes diarios y ahora solamente son
dos o tres los que visitan las
instalaciones denuncian que precisamente
estas señalamientos a las personas
homosexuales
hace que sea más difícil acceder
antirretrovirales son los medicamentos
que permiten mantener la infección de
VIH a raya digamos intransmisible y por
lo tanto también indetectable que es
difícil incluso acceder a Protección
como unos condones no en esta clínica de
más de campana era un ejemplo de éxito
de la lucha contra el VIH en el país en
un lugar como jugando donde mueren
17.000 personas anuales por culpa de
infecciones de VIH y los doctores ya te
ven que esto esté haciendo que aumenten
los contagios escuchamos un testimonio
que se dio en condiciones de anonimato
Desde que la ley entró en vigora ha
habido muchos cambios en la búsqueda de
atención sanitaria por ejemplo en el
apoyo de donantes y aliados
algunos aliados han retirado su apoyo y
hay donantes que temen seguir dándonos
apoyo
Porque pueden ser identificados como
promotores de inducir a los jóvenes a la
homosexualidad
[Música]
además penaliza con cadena perpetua no
en lo que llama homosexualidad grabada
según concepto absolutamente fuera de
cualquier lógica pero es que además uno
de estos casos de homosexualidad
agravada es tener VIH y tener relaciones
sexuales con alguien del mismo género
bajo la ley de uganda no algo que
insistimos no tiene mucho sentido porque
las infecciones de VIH no distinguen
realmente cuál es tu orientación asexual
no es una no es un contagio que pueda
suceder exclusivamente en las personas
homosexuales o en los hombres que tienen
sexo con hombres por lo tanto no tiene
mucho sentido penalizarlo de esta forma
y además Pues en este sentido sabemos
que uganda es una de las más recientes
no ha sido uno de los más de los casos
más mediáticos pero no son los únicos
países que tienen leyes que pueden
penalizar o discriminar a la población
lgbt Y en este caso vamos con las cifras
de un estudio que se publicó en adelante
hace unos años que compara Cuáles son
por ejemplo las pruebas de VIH en países
con leyes más severas o menos severas en
este caso únicamente del continente
africano y vemos que en los países donde
las leyes son menos severas más laxas
hay más personas que se han hecho prueba
de VIH en toda su vida hay más personas
que se han hecho pruebas de VIH en el
último año y hay más personas que
conocen su condición que saben que están
enfermos o contagiados de VIH algo que
es absolutamente indispensable para
evitar la transmisión y también para
salvar vidas No claro mal al final la
criminalización la persecución o no al
final solo aboca la gente a más
peligrosos Bueno muchísimas gracias mar
por este repaso Gracias Rosa hasta
mañana